die die somebody just oh god oh blew up
[Music]
driving in Los Angeles is chaotic you
really just got to learn to cut people
off I have never had a road accident oh
that's a lie I drive every day and
basically all day long I'm a very safe
driver I describe my driving style as
pretty conservative when I'm not on a
race track I think one skill that I have
that probably a regular driver might not
is the ability to look ahead and see the
turns that are coming up this is a brand
new racing game so none of us have any
experience with it so we're on equal
Playing Fields however I still think I'm
gonna win I am not intimidated by these
two at all honestly I was pretty
confident and now I'm kind of nervous
cars okay I'm gonna go with the hot dog
because I like hot dogs baby shark
that's so cute it matches my outfits
let's go sports cars first all right so
skins let's see if we can Gussy this
sucker up a little bit
I'm going night alien wait can I upgrade
this I want to make sure the best perks
enemies that hit your pizza Shield are
instantly destroyed that sounds good
I got a weapon who is this daddy person
I'm killing things get out of here all
right just leave me alone oh my God I
found people reach oh reach radio we
gotta go to the where the Green Arrow is
oh right here
we're getting nailed let's not be silly
13 15. how is he not dead
why let me stay on this because they're
trying to kill you just wail on them
blew up oh my God someone's killing me
from behind no I'm out Finish Line hey
you didn't die you did good good good
round finish I'm still confident I'm a
little nervous I've got an adrenaline
rush I'm sweating over here okay it's
time to go into our battle round and
whoever gets the highest score wins
[Music]
towards the campgrounds all right so I
just got the Nitro boost reached early
battle ballerina's right there but I
need a gun first I love me a donut time
to make the donuts you guys I have a
pizza Shield
oh my God he's tearing me apart 13 15.
come here hey buddy what's going on
how's your day oh
I just got bang bang Jade Daddy I'm
gonna kill Jay Daddy all right here's a
quick trip let me get over here my life
is going down oh ramp
oh my God it boosts you I'm gonna kill
Jay daddy so bad all right I'm at the QT
I'm gonna get back into my battle arena
and I just switched into donut mode but
I've just switched back to roller grill
artillery and now it's time for everyone
to get shelled man there's a lot of
action happening right here die die die
there's a lot of guns die there's a lot
of killing wait it looks like I'm on
fire what's going on here oh they're
killing me with the donuts
oh god oh wait I want to go back to QT
because I'm almost dead oh I hit the
building I'm sorry I just switched my
vehicle and I picked up a machine gun so
let's see if that helps me out so if you
don't get into these zones fast enough
you lose hit points I have just lost a
ton does he have like a shield or
something what's going on oh
I got him
okay I finished the round I'm at the
finish line
that's good
I guess what happened I dominated my
most important weapon was the machine
gun I just got to shoot people with hot
dogs my favorite part of the game is
that I could actually go to the QT to
get fixed when I was really down on hit
points and I was gonna die my advice for
new users would be just look out for
donuts don't hit them make sure you pay
attention to the Green Arrow
foreign
place with 855 points we have Mika
[Applause]
in second place
with
1240 points grams
our first place is Michael with 1260
points
thank you very much oh guys I've been
training a long time for this
um I want to thank my Mom and Dad
congratulations yes congrats like you
really needed this where is the
champagne
thank you